[Music]
[Music]
my father said I ought to go to Boston
Tech and there was a kid named Tom
Peters who went east to Harvard and when
he came over in the summer I said beep
there tom did you ever hear of a Boston
Tech well he said no they they changed
the name they moved it from Boston over
to Cambridge and they call it the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and then he looked me right in the eye
and said real loud they only take smart
ones no no no I learned from that not to
ever believe anything at the Harvard
person tells you well it seems like
yesterday that I came over here in 1926
to look over MIT I had been working in
Schenectady New York at the General
Electric Company and was admitted as a
graduate student in electrical
engineering to work on motors it was
during the course of his graduate
studies and electrical engineering that
doc designed and developed the stroke he
needed a way to observe parts that move
so quickly that they were a blur and it
was for this purpose that he invented
something new an incredibly brief
controllable and repeatable flash I
worked for three years on motors and I
suddenly realized hey there's a lot of
things in the world that move
they looked around there was a faucet
all this right next to her ring so I
just moved stole and took a picture this
water can that was the first picture I
ever took except for a motor and
Edgerton found that there were other
ways to study motion by repeatedly
flashing a strobe he could create
multiple images on a single photograph
[Music]
now this is amol flash picture so
there's the lights running a hundred
times a second I got two big powerful
strobe lights well here comes the club
see it's accelerating and you can fly
too curved into the velocity versus time
and you give the Garver information he
isn't the slightest bit interested in
such as the velocity of his T now this
picture uh was a fizzle I normally throw
away all my bad negatives and I just
about to throw this out and I'll make a
pic print of that and this down the
museum Modern Art in New York both being
real art I don't care that sorry if they
want to call it ice money all right
well I raising myself as a more
electrical engineer because it's all
done with electricity you saw these bold
flights around here they're all
batteries and capacitors and electronic
lamps
[Music]
there was a somebody come in here from
MGM and he said I want a movie of
throwing a custard pie through an
electric fan well I said I'm a serious
scientist I'm not gonna fool with any
custard pies but let's let's compromise
on an egg what do you say the film was
called quicker and a wink and it won a
1936 Academy Award for MGM I always
thought that my cat in lapping her milk
curled her tongue up but now it's
revealed that she curls her tongue down
see in other words she brings the milk
up on the underside of her tongue now
see how smart you get when you go to the
movie years later doc and his colleagues
added the finishing touch matching slow
motion sound to high-speed pictures this
was made in the war when we were we were
having in trouble with the Germans we
used to want to know what they were
doing at nighttime
the year was 1938 doc and his associates
went to work on the top-secret project
the end result was a 57,000 watt second
strobe package powered by eight
kilowatts and weighing 3,700 pounds the
value of the aerial strobe is
dramatically demonstrated the night
before the invasion of Normandy the
photos showed little or no movement of
enemy troops
indicating that the Germans were
unprepared for the invasion the clouds
were down about a thousand feet and the
flash bomb couldn't use it all because
they were designed to be working at
10,000 feet so those pictures were
useful
they were used all during war the Atomic
Energy Commission asked Edgerton and his
associates kermis Heusen and Greer to
form a company which later became EG&G
and to design a testing camera to
analyze nuclear explosions
and then suddenly one day we had a
agreement with the Russians not to have
any more atom bombs all my friends came
around here and said the law was too bad
your company's going down a drain well
that was the best year we ever had
because all the people got up early in
the morning started thinking about other
things to do and was all kinds of things
to do doc turned his stroke to the
undersea world where movement was
sometimes imperceptible by having a
movie camera takes one picture every 20
seconds and you can take things that
happen slowly and speed them up now I
was trying to get these sand dollar to
spill MIT they're very poor learners
very poor I asked him to bring some of
those sand dollars back cuz my grandson
wanted to see him actually it was me I
wanted to see him but that's all right
hello run on things they got small feet
on the bottom so they can walk around up
Eric up raise them up and avoid
[Music]
I got a telephone call they said there
was some unknown man come in from from
France named jacques-yves cousteau and
nobody heard him but he's here and could
he come up and talk to you about
underwater photography so he came in and
I found out he'd invented the Aqualung
and he hadn't been an MIT more than a
couple hours before we had a tank on his
back and he was testing my latest
underwater strobes in the swimming pool
and that led to a many many expeditions
on the Calypso and a lot of article in
the geographic Edgerton found that sonar
could be used to make pictures with
sound justice photographs are made with
light at Boston's Charles River he
developed and tested a whole new array
of sonar devices one called a Boomer or
ping er penetrates the underwater mud to
reveal objects below another of Edgerton
sonar inventions is a side scanner used
to locate objects which project above
the bottom of the sea I was in Athens
with Cousteau on the clip so and he came
in one day and said he's that side scan
sonar good for picking up a ship that's
a thousand feet long I think you can
find it well I said if I can't we better
go on this honor you don't be able to
find it no time long ways where anybody
ever thought there was just as clear and
sharp when MIT has it opened yards to
the Linux thousands of copies of his
famous and Ultron pictures and gives
them away to what he helps maybe a
future steal the milk drop is probably
the best known picture that dr. Edgerton
has ever taken but he is equally well
known as a superb teacher now I will try
to find it with the strobe and this disc
is used in music for tuning instruments
you swing it over microphone it changed
the frequency of the light you look at a
disc it's run by a constant speed motor
and you can tell where the girls singing
clatters sharp or whatever it is some
people could tell without this stove if
you ticket interested in these things we
got here way come on down and run him
[Applause]
several years ago I heard gene brown
make a remark that she hadn't been
married to Gordon very long before she
realized that he had another loved MIT I
too had the same experience when I
married Harold unfortunately it didn't
take me very long to become enamored
with MIT myself and so we've been a
happy trying ever since
when the first miracles happened to me
it was when I was about five years old
and my father brought home a beautiful
Jersey cow and he let it into the barn
and my sister and I went in after him
and we were both given cups by my mother
and we'd put him under the faucet and
drink that warm milk out of that cow it
was really an experience to remember
I also remember there was a smart-aleck
kid from Omaha that's a big town you
know I lived in a little town and he
says how does it work well I say you put
hay and water in one end and there's a
kind of a bag on the other with those
four things that stick him down here and
he says wow those four well I said one
of them is for milk another one's for
skim milk another one's for cream he
says what's the other one for
I said that's for chocolate milk now you
can see even when I was five years old I
was an educator yeah but see my question
is even even if this goes off in one
millionth of a second right if your
shutter speed is not that quick you're
not going to shatter the camera you're
doing the darkroom and you let all
exposure come from the light there you
go I didn't realize that you've learned
something tonight congratulations a lot
of things I can't do I just say push
that over that's for the next generation
finally this evening our person of the
week it is unusual for us to choose
someone who just died we do so this week
because as often happens only when
someone dies does a really large
audience of people come to realize and
appreciate how much that person had
accomplished and we are all so much more
enlightened because of this man's
imagination doc Edgerton the scientist
and teacher who wanted to be remembered
as much for his views on life as much as
for the life he enabled us to view and
so we choose Harold doc Edgerton who has
died at 86 tinkerer and visionary he
shed light where there was only shadow
he enlarged the world for scientists
historians and those of us just with
family scrapbooks he was most personally
dedicated to those thousands of people
who passed through
classroom I'm just a crazy old professor
he said crazy like a fox
[Music]